The values for m are 1/8 and 1/2. Nice solving if you found these two
fractions. We can replace u with what it equaled from our substitution 4m minus
3. So, this u becomes 4m minus 3, and this u becomes 4m minus 3 as well. Next,
we add 3 to both sides of the equation to get 4m equals negative 5 halves plus
3, and 4m equals 2. Here I want to combine these two together, so this added
together should be positive 1/2. If I haven't convinced you, then think about
what we can change 3 into. We can change what this number looks like by writing
it as a fraction. 3 is the same as 6 divided by 2. So, really we have negative
5 halves, plus 6 halves. We'll have one more positive halve on this side than
we do negative halve. So, these added together will give us positive 2 halves.
Finally, we divide by 4 on both sides of the equations to get m is equal to 1/2
times 1/4, and m is equal to 1/2. I know this is true, since, when we divide by
a number, we can really multiply it by its reciporical. So, 1/2 divided by 4 is
1/2 times 1/4. And we know that really equals 1/8. So, 1/8 is one solution, and
1/2 is the other.